qui seront les participants au vote pour
le président des républicains eh bien ce
sont les adhérents à jour de cotisation
depuis le 15 décembre 2021
jusqu'au 3 novembre
2022 soit 30 jours avant le scrutin
voilà le corps électoral qui pourra se
prononcer ça veut dire chers amis qu'il
faut si vous voulez participer au choix
du président du futur président ou de la
future présidente bien il faut à des
faits renouveler votre adhésion vous
avez pour cela jusqu'au 3 novembre ce
sera un scrutin à deux tours si
nécessaire le 3 et le 4 décembre et une
semaine après un éventuel second tour
donc les candidats et bien ils ont
jusqu'au jusqu'au 3 octobre pour
remettre leurs parrainages puisqu'on ne
peut pas se présenter sans être parrainé
par un certain nombre de personnes des
adhérents et des parlementaires et donc
ses parrainages devons être remis le 3
octobre soit 60 jours avant le scrutin
et la publication de la liste des
candidats se fera au plus tard le 18
octobre après que la haute autorité aura
validé les parrainages et donc les
candidats